thank you
[Music]
so this isn't something that's in like
entirely new but it's really cool to see
the actual figures
um you know how the Army was trying to
like boost recruitment with Gen Z by
trying to uh
Marshall well no they were trying to
integrate with uh Call of Duty
they chatted a bunch of different ideas
some of them was like uh to get a lot of
popular streamers that stream Call of
Duty to kind of uh you know talk about
the army or run ads or they wanted to do
a you know Call of Duty Mobile on your
phone they wanted to be able to like
reward you for watching Army ads like
you'd get more perks and [ __ ] have you
seen the military thoughts that's
probably the military like girls
thoughts like like they're saying that
the th they're saying like they're like
the um they're like the recruitment
tactic of the military now where they'll
just have like tick tocks and [ __ ] and
they're like you can do both like get a
girl that can vote that does a [ __ ]
military and then boobs and then like
bikini it's like a Barracks bunny type
thing are they trying to get more girls
to join oh they're trying to get more
guys to Children if you're in the
military you'll be with girls like this
yeah the turkey ladies are in now yeah
there's a lot of sexual assault that
happens 100 000 guys there's that new
yeah there's a new documentary about
that one chick that came out yeah
Vanessa yeah that shit's [ __ ] up it's
really [ __ ] up but yeah the um the the
funny irony of that is that they they
were gonna partner with Activision to do
like a across the board
um collab with everything Call of Duty
and US Army and they pulled out of it
because Activision started getting
um sexual harassment scandals oh really
so the Army pulled out from that really
what was what was happening with that
workplace sexual harassment stuff oh I
don't even know girls work there a lot
of the gaming companies have that
problem because there's so many [ __ ]
they're so male dominated
well uh blizzard had that problem right
now that's Activision yeah they were it
was like specifically blizzard like was
accused of all that kind of [ __ ] and
Activision was like helping to cover it
up which kind of shows it's not really
an alpha male thing it's like beta males
too it's always been that it's just like
like you know movies aren't going to
show that because it's not that
interesting to look at yeah yeah right
well it's like I don't think gamers are
the right demo you want for to be in the
Army right well drone strikes it's it's
not that they want Gamers it's just they
want gen Z and a lot of gen Z they're
recruitments at an all-time low so
that's worldwide though for sure so
there's a there's a chart that came out
that nobody's trying to kill people for
the government anymore
spending on the certain things that they
wanted to put budget towards so you see
right there at the top where it says 1
million that's for like a twitch uh Call
of Duty like competition they wanted to
uh sponsor it so you can spend a million
on that it says that's where our tax
dollars are going
twitch marketing campaigns right 300 000
was going to go to a streamer named
optic who's like does a lot of Call of
Duty streams stuff like that most of
these guys are like just reg uh
streamers yeah on platforms bless you
WWE 675 Grand yeah they should give them
more I mean it does work though because
my
um so my cousin he uh his clients was
were talking about oh my son all he does
is play video games and [ __ ] right yeah
that's all he does just plays these
shooting games and [ __ ] and then he
joined the military and he became like a
top [ __ ] sniper whoa well that never
happened it's very rare yeah
so he was like oh [ __ ] if that's
actually something that works man I mean
I feel like most Gamers it doesn't
translate to wanting to do that thing in
real life especially like twitch right
because it's almost like a that is the
escape it's like the the shooting guns
part is like
frosting on the cake although I will say
when I play Grand Theft Auto I started
driving way bad like really I feel like
I started seeing like shop lights I'm
like nah I don't have to no yeah I'll
just run this person though oh [ __ ] no I
do have that I was playing a lot of
Grand Theft Auto yeah it does GTA does
give you that feeling when you see a
nice car in real life you just think you
can open the door and get in but you're
like oh wait that's not my car when
you've been playing it for too long that
means you just your brain immediately
thinks of the bad thing and then you're
like whoa yeah yeah you're like hold on
wait there's a pedestrian I should oh no
no no and then I'll run over their caps
yeah yeah yeah have you guys ever seen
uh did you guys ever watch Penn and
Teller [ __ ] yeah all the time I love
it this kid who was like obsessed with
games and Call of Duty and he loves
shooting and all this stuff and they
wanted to prove that a kid who's
obsessed with Call of Duty does not want
to shoot a real gun oh yeah because
that's the the numbing the [ __ ] is
like they want to shoot up at school
exactly yeah Columbine on videos exactly
yeah Marilyn Manson so they took him to
the range this this little kid and they
put a gun in his hand they were like
they're like forcing him to basically
like shoot targets and he didn't want to
do it he started crying and he like had
a [ __ ] mental breakdown would he like
to play shooting games yeah I loved him
but he was like that's not the same it's
not related it's not related yeah that
would have been so much fun to the other
way the kids
they cast a new kid the first kid was
like that and they're like
and that's kind of the big thing that
you were saying with the escapism of it
it's like a lot of people put on
personalities during games online that
they don't necessarily even have in real
life yeah like the parts the parts that
I feel like that does work are like the
high school recruiting where they set up
a pull-up bar or whatever and like the
kids that are like playing sports or
they're act they're like more fit
they're probably more prone to being
more successful during Boot Camp or
whatever and they have like these these
little boots at um all the fitness Expos
too I feel like that's a good
demographic but it is declining like
crazy yeah because when I play a guitar
hero I try to play guitar and I was like
oh it's too hard it's boring I gotta
learn a bunch of
Guitar Hero and then I tried a real
guitar
oh no yeah this simulation is what's fun
like when you do rock band remember like
when someone's on the drums and then the
thing yeah that was so fun but it's like
we're not gonna go [ __ ] you know it's
a lazy version yeah exactly even like
like um like you know how he played
Airsoft yesterday right like some people
they don't want to do AirSoft but
they'll play Call of Duty or all that
stuff because they don't want to get off
their chair exactly exactly yeah it's
not connected but the thing is they're
not trying to decide to play Call of
Duty the interesting here the
interesting thing here is that they're
not trying to say that Call of Duty
people make good people for the Army
it's just that's what most kids that's
the age group
yeah if they were doing something else
the Army would be there like it doesn't
matter like what it is well maybe if
they did more um targeted like teenage
movies but with like a military theme
maybe that would work too like Teenage
mood what is that like ROTC like Pitch
Perfect Right like that's about acapella
so if you're trying to hit that age
group you have to hit that age group
across all their viewing pleasure but
teenage movies Target mostly the female
demographic because it's like YouTube
like the female the makeup artist like
the it's like teenagers yeah but it's
like mostly female look at Top Gun right
like like there's a reason why you go
over the credits and it's like thanks
special thanks Department of Defense
Department of Homeland Security
Department because that is propaganda
for joining the military like look at
how sick it is
always been part of the model but then
they got all these old guys watching
they can't recruit them do you feel like
any recruitment tactic that the military
may have used translated to your
motivation to want to be in it oh yeah
when 911 was an inside job it made me
really like spirited for my country
whoa so you never signed up though is
that when you did your it's because it
didn't happen
whoa come on don't give me stuff to clip
vanity is a big conspiracy theory hey
cut that out guys
I don't want it in there anymore I don't
want it in there yeah take it out check
it out
okay dude well the number one pretending
it's a bit okay
I don't know man I think I needed the I
don't think I needed the marketing like
I was just he was pumped today I was
just like you know like Army crawling
like on the [ __ ] front line we were
all playing Rambo that was the [ __ ] that
I wanted so like I me and my friends
went to the recruiter's office like it
wasn't like I'm walking like what the
[ __ ] you guys doing here I don't know
people just did it I feel like it's
those type of guys and then people that
don't have a direction in life that are
like I don't know what to do with my
life and like oh well like they'll pay
for school if I do this I feel like yeah
that was the best ad I think actually
that would always show up on TV and it
was like they'll pay for my college
they'll pay for this and that and all I
knew is my parents couldn't pay for
college so I was like maybe it's a good
idea and a lot of the directionless
people like in the in my family I
actually recommend the military because
they kind of teach you about the world
from the ground up like if your parents
never touch out of iron or like just
like really basic [ __ ] right like you
start with a little Foot Locker like how
to keep your hygiene kit or like
understand how taxes kind of work and
like because they teach you all that
stuff like even basic budgeting they
save some for taxes like they literally
build you that sounds better than actual
school one brother that didn't go to
military from the ground up so when you
graduate boot camp like you're like kind
of kind of like a functioning 18 19 year
old and they kind of fill in all the
gaps that school might have left you so
I'm like that's kind of cool doing all
the gaps huh
what are you guys thinking about right
now there's a guest with a gap she has a
gap yeah she has a gap and you just said
you want to fill it what kind of gift
who's got to go stop saying baby guess
that oh my god wow you want to fill baby
gaps You Got a Baby Gap that's
disgusting I'm expecting hey cut that
out look at that I love how instantly
everyone becomes straight man when
Anthony makes a joke
it's things like this you guys should
fire me
[Music]